>> Product in Google Apps.
>> NICHOLS: Great. Thanks, David. Appreciate
the introduction. My name's Ryan. I'm from
Appirio, a cloud solution provider working
with Google on bringing these Gmail contextual
gadgets to the enterprise. So if we switch
to the demo, I'm going to show you what it's
like to run your entire enterprise in the
cloud. That's not just what we do, uh, for
our customers at Appirio, it's how we run
our own business. And now with Gmail contextual
gadgets, in a new product called PS Connect
from Appirio, I can do that all from Google
Apps. This is the best integrated app in the
Marketplace. So I manage a team of consultants
at Appirio. Uh, I need some serious Enterprise
applications in order to keep tabs on my people,
my projects, my customers, my financials and
I do all of that in the cloud. Here are my
operational applications. You see that I use,
um, salesforce.com to manage my leads and
my opportunities. You see that I use, uh,
PS Enterprise. It's a force.com-based application
to manage my people and my projects. There
is a lot of data in all of these Enterprise
applications. But, of course, this isn't really
where I run my business on a day-to-day business--uh,
day-to-day basis. This is--my Google Apps
inbox. I mean, this is where I make dozens
of decisions every day that impact every part
of my--my, uh, my operations. But I make these
decisions without having access to all the
business data that's in all those other business
applications. What if I could use Google Apps
as the front-end to those operational applications?
Well, now with Gmail contextual gadgets and
PS Connect, I can do exactly that. Let me
show you how it works. When I go into my inbox
in the morning, first thing I do is hone in
on emails from customers. Here's an email
from a customer of mine. Looks like he wants
to grab lunch. Now, normally, I might not
prioritize responding to this particular email.
Doesn't seem urgent. I certainly wouldn't
go and look up Carl Customer in our CRM Database
to find out what's going on with that account.
That's just not what I'm doing right now.
I'm doing my email. But that would be a mistake.
Look at the bottom of this email. You see
something new. It's called PS Connect. It's
a contextual gadget that's taken this email--who
it's from, who it's to, what it's about--and
gone and fetched the information from all
those different systems that I need to make
the right decision about how to reply to this
message. So I see that Carl Customer actually
has five opportunities open with us right
now. One of those opportunities--this office
relocation service--is actually on hold until
the New York office move has been finalized
at the customer. Well, guess what? I just
learned in the email that the New York office
move has been finalized. This is great news.
Now I can take action on that insight right
from Google Apps. I can change the stage of
this opportunity, and qualify it, and say
"This is now qualified because the office
move's been finalized." I can add this email
to my CRM system so that the entire account
team is up to speed on what's going on in
this account. Normally, I wouldn't have done
either of these things until the night before
our weekly sales call. But it's not just CRM.
PS Connect also exposes capabilities from
my transactional applications. You see this
button down here "New Resource Request." This
is functionality in our PS Enterprise product
that allows me to give my staffing team a
heads up. But I'm gonna need a little bit
of support from an analyst next week to help
me prepare for this customer lunch. Again,
normally, I wouldn't do this until our weekly
staffing call. But now I can trigger a set
of actions across my organization as I'm going
through my email in sales and now in staffing.
And because I've taken those actions, I can
now reply to this customer with an appropriate
degree of urgency. Right? I can tell him "Sounds
great. Let's meet next week." This is more
than just saving me clicks. This is actually
helping me make a different decision about
how to respond to my emails as I go through
my day. So far, so good. Let's see what's
next in my email inbox. This email doesn't
look like it's such good news. It's from a
customer who seems to be a little upset about
the status of their project. Now, normally,
this would trigger a flurry of activity across
my organization. "Whose project is this? What's
the status? What's the plan to get these guys
back on track? A lot of that data is actually
in my PS Enterprise application, but PS Connect
can bring that to my attention in the context
of the email. You see that we actually have
three projects open with this customer right
now. Looks like this development project is
the one that's giving me trouble. I have the
status and a note from the project manager
right here. We're going to remain behind schedule
until we're able to extend the engagement
of it--uh, the architect. I also have data
that PS Connect has brought to help me decide
whether extending that engagement is a good
business move. I see that while a couple of
our projects are out of budget or over budget,
this project actually has some extra budget
associated with it. So, um, maybe I can extend
the team. Well, I'm right here in Google Apps.
I can go ahead and, uh, and--and chat with
our staffer here and say, you know, "Can I,
uh, can I extend Acme?" If he says yes, then
I can go ahead and take action on this, right?
I can go ahead right in the context of Google
Apps, bring up, like, another piece of PS
Enterprise functionality. This time, it's
my project planner. This is a view of all
the projects that I have open at this account
where I can drill in. I can take a look at
this Acme Development account, and all the
people assigned to it, and take a look at
our architect here, his schedule, and right
in the context of my, uh, uh, of my email,
extend his engagement. I can update the schedule,
go back to this email, and again, reply right
away. I've not just saved clicks going from
one tab to another, I've made a different
decision. The team is extended. Customer will
be thrilled to hear this. So you can see that
things are a little different when you run
your entire business in the cloud. You are
able to bring together context for multiple
different business applications and use them
right in the context of your day-to-day work.
Thanks to Gmail contextual gadgets and Appirio
PS Connect. PS Connect is, uh, in Beta right
now with some of, uh, the customers of Appirio
PS Enterprise. You can learn more at appirio.com
or in the Google Marketplace. Thanks. [pause]
>> Thank you, Ryan. You just saw some of the--the
deeper integration that's possible as we keep
adding more and more extensions into Google
Apps--more places for more--more of you as
developers to have your apps add more great
functionality into Google Apps. This list
of extension points is gonna keep growing
over time with suggestions from you all. We're
looking forward to seeing all the great ideas
that--that you come up with to take advantage
of this. So let me recap what you've seen
tonight. We walked you through the three steps
that it takes to have you as a company--as
a developer-- take part in the Google Apps
Marketplace. First step: build your applications.
Take a-- have an idea. Build an application
that does something useful for your business
customers in the cloud. Second step, integrate.
Take advantage of as few or as many of the
points of integration that are available in
Google Apps to solve your bus--your applications'
needs. To do what makes sense for your customers,
your use cases, on how they integrate with
Google Apps. And then third, once you've built
your integration and tell Google about it,
in the--in the Marketplace, list your application
and start reaching out to new customers. Start
doing business. Start making money selling
apps to your customers in the cloud who are
our customers in the cloud, working together
to make the world of Google Apps bigger and
have more capabilities for more users. Talking
about customers, talking about the business
opportunity, I'd like to bring up Dave Girouard,
the President of our Google Enterprise Division
who's been leading Google forward as we do
that up into the right growth of Google Apps.
And--and--and is working with all of us. And
is looking forward to working with all of
you to do the same with the Google Apps Marketplace.
Dave.
>> GIROUARD: Thank you. Thanks, Dave. Good
to be here. I'll be brief. I have neither
slides nor demos. Um, but you've--maybe you've
seen enough of those. I-I just want to, uh,
say a few words. When I joined Google several
years ago, uh, not only was there no Google
Apps, there was no apps. Um, Gmail launched
as a product on April Fools' Day in 2004 soon
after I joined. And, uh, that was our very,
uh, controversial launch into our apps business.
Um, it was really--it's really been about
three years. And I should say, by the way,
I-I joined to lead our enterprise initiative--which
is really a unique thing for Google and I
think a thing that a lot of people don't understand
that well--uh, really with the goal of taking
innovation that happens typically very quickly
on the consumer side in a way that is very
focused on the end user experience and delivering
that in a business context to small businesses,
large businesses, cities, towns, governments,
schools. Um, really trying to take the best
of both worlds--the innovation and the user
centricity you find in the consumer world,
but then also layering in the things that
businesses, and schools, and others care about,
which is security, manageability, cost, et
cetera. And this cloud computing thing seems
to be the right formula to do just that. So,
uh, we started about three years ago--as most
of you that are here today probably know--
um, with a very modest effort. And, uh, in
the first week, Google Apps signed up 9,000
businesses, uh, in--in, uh, February of 2007.
So we--we kind of knew we were on to something
and it has grown really quickly since then.
Um, as you heard earlier from Vick, we now
have 25 million active users of Google Apps,
uh, across businesses and schools. Uh, we
have more than 2 million businesses. And the
growth rate has accelerated. There's about
a 300% increase in the sign-up rate, um, for
our premier products just in the last year.
So we are in a fairly dramatic acceleration
period. We've also done a lot of things I
think are pretty compelling. The higher education
market, which is never, you know, known as
really the--the aggressive, first adopters
of technology, has really moved to the cloud
wholesale. We've bec--